let's speak to a few more people
davidpackman.com Discord is the place to
do it let's go to Sammy in New York City
Sammy what's going on
Sammy in New York City please unmute
yourself you have self-muted and that is
why no one can hear you you are on the
air but you have muted yourself Sammy
and if you unmute yourself yes can you
hear me yes oh my God finally I got
through
um David quick question and you might
have already answered this in another uh
podcast and I'd love your show by the
way thank you um
if
um
Mike Pence had said it had agreed with
Donald Trump and said hey you know what
I am going to stop the election uh of
Biden what would have hit like what
would that process have been like I mean
I know he couldn't but like he's like
okay yeah I'm gonna do it yeah this is a
very good question
I can't say that I can tell you for
certain exactly what the sequence would
have been if Pence did try to stop the
election from being certified right I
don't believe he ultimately would have
succeeded but I think it would have been
very dangerous and it probably would
have been something like
Pence would say in certain States like
when they get to Arizona saying we give
our votes to Biden Pence would have said
something like
you know due to the controversy
outstanding and
I am not going to accept those electoral
votes
if he wanted to go further he could have
said I'm going to recognize an alternate
slate of electors and that would have
probably become a constitutional crisis
if he simply rejected to accept some my
understanding is that it just lowers the
total number
and it lowers the number you need to be
president from 270 to something lower
and by will probably still becomes
president but with people but the point
is it would have been extremely
dangerous and it would have been a
perilous moment for our democracy
right and obviously he couldn't have
carried it out anyway I agree he's been
such a Trump's like you know of his
yeah the whole while so I'm just was
curious about that and David I'm so
excited to talk to you like I watch you
every day yes thank you so amazing I
appreciate that yes absolutely and you
know good luck to your family
um and um I'm
I'm I'm just blown away at how amazingly
informative you are I love you I really
appreciate that I'm sure you're
subscribed to the YouTube channel
I knew I had a feeling Sammy that you're
I am all right thank you so much for the
call I appreciate it my pleasure have a
good day Sammy from the city great great
stuff